Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to Simon from
Montana? Simon, welcome to the program. What's
going on in Montana? Amy? Yes, I can.
Speaker 3:
Oh, that's awesome. Long time
viewer. I really love your
show and I look forward to it every day.
Speaker 1: Well, I appreciate that. What's
it like living in Montana? I have a friend who's
a doctor who does medicine seasonally in Montana
and finds it very, very interesting place.
Speaker 3: Oh, that's. That's awesome.
Do you know what town he lives in?
Speaker 1: Well, I don't want to say.
Oh, because it's so rural there that there might
only be ten people in that town. And everyone
will know who I'm talking about, you know?
Speaker 3: Yeah. Yes, absolutely. Well,
it's very cold right now. And yeah, a lot of a
lot of red. I live in sort of a blue bubble in
one of the two blue bubbles, I will say.
Speaker 1: So you don't have like a 45 minute
drive to get groceries or anything like that.
Speaker 3: No, that's fine. It's. It's pretty
good here, that's for sure. It's all right.
Speaker 1: If you want to go to, like,
Europe, do you have to what you fly to,
like Chicago and then Chicago to Europe?
Or is it more complicated than that?
Speaker 3: Um, well, our airport goes,
I would say we generally, we take our airport to
Yeah, somewhere like I guess Spokane or something
like that is generally where I've been going.
Speaker 1: But from, from Spokane, I can't imagine
you're getting to London, for example, Right?
Speaker 3: Oh, no. Well, I've only been to
Mexico out of the country. Okay. I believe we
went somewhere near Spokane Fair. And then.
Speaker 1: Well, what's. I've
had so many questions. It
seems only fair to allow you to ask one.
Speaker 3: Well, thank you. I appreciate
them. And I was just I've been wondering
for the last couple of weeks, I know you've
talked about the migrant busing stunts that are
absolutely disgusting and horrible, deplorable.
And I just wanted to know, obviously, these
people like Greg Abbott and DeSantis are doing it
because they feel like it scores them
political points with their base. Right.
Otherwise, they wouldn't continue to do it. I was
wondering, like as the left, as a media sphere,
what can we do to prevent to stop that? Or I think
we should be aiming resources at preventing this
from being something that scores them political
points because so little obviously so horrifying.
Speaker 1: If it doesn't score them political
points. So so here, here's the issue. If it
does score them political points, I don't know
that the left can do much about that because
it's working and their constituents like it. I do
think being on the same page about explaining why
it's deplorable and disgusting makes sense so that
hopefully people who hear about it that might say,
Oh, that's interesting, that proves a
point. Then they hear, Oh, actually,
here's why it's crazy and it's financially a
disaster and it's immoral and it's unethical
and it's treating people like objects and pawns,
etc.. But what really we need is an electorate
where it wouldn't score the many points. So it's
a much broader change that needs to be effected.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Yeah. It's definitely a bit of
a wicked issue there. Yeah. Yeah. So. Well, yeah,
that was pretty much all that's on my mind.
And it really is like I'm a big, strong guy,
but with tears in my eyes. It is an honor to.
Speaker 1: Talk to you. And just last thing.
Can you get a good bagel in Montana?
Speaker 3: Oh, God, no, sir.
Speaker 1: Okay. Thank you very much. Well, now
I'm the one who has tears in his eyes. Thanks.
Thanks for the call, Simon. I appreciate it. Of
course, we're going to take the quickest of breaks
if you're still holding, we're going right back
to the phones. So I would I would suggest that
you stay with me here. Very quick break and then
we will be right back and hear from more of you.